[Music]
nice
but the mistake he made when he was 13
ruined his life
forever no more contract no more pro
career
no more cs go and in his darkest hour
a new game got him to break up with cs
and finally unleash his potential
oh my god is this just getting away from
sewer look at this they're all funny
hopping up
the massacre is so yummy it's a reload
and still finds
oculus
that's available still for gtm he could
make a very quick rotation back into mid
if he wanted to
instead what okay that's nine kills in
two rounds he's just
aced it
if you've heard yampi's name you've
probably heard one of two things about
him
either that he's a cs go prodigy cruelly
cut out of his prime by an unfair vac
man
or that he's the hottest name in
european valorant
yampi has been playing cs go
professionally since 2017 but he'd been
playing the game casually for years
before then
and 2015 is when things started to go
wrong for him
a young yampi and his buddies were
having a lan party at yampi's house
now not everybody owns cs go so he took
his parents credit card with permission
i assume
bought a bunch of copies and started
handing them out now at least one of
those friends pays him back
that night for the game thus in some way
transferring
ownership of that account from yampi to
his buddy
basically yampi says he bought a copy of
cs go for a friend
and that friend eventually got vacman
for allegedly cheating
unfortunately since gampy was the one
who owns the account that bought the
game
he's the one who had to carry the burden
of a vac man forever
for most players getting backband isn't
that big a deal
but if you want to go pro it's a death
now for the longest time
vac man players couldn't compete in cs
go majors which basically made them
unsignable to tier 1 teams
yampy played for a bunch of small time
finished rosters that were never really
going to go anywhere
but as the years went on it became clear
that his vac ban was holding him back
in october 2019 og was rumored to be
looking at yampi for their first ever cs
go roster
but then the deal fell through allegedly
because og was scared off by his vac ban
i heard that i'm not turning og like my
motivation just went off and
i even played like almost two men once
with sj after that but yeah i was not
i would say i was like zero motivated
that that and
it was not fun times at least for me and
probably not as a team because i was not
always like super focused about our team
practice and stuff like that
at this point you'd think that the best
option for yampy was to pack up and
leave cs go forever he was never going
to get signed while he was vac banned
but he loved the game too much just quit
so he sued valve in march 2020 yampi
sued valve for just over a quarter of a
million euros for alleged damages as a
result of the vac ban
the apes legal team argued that the ban
was unreasonable that he never cheated
and that he didn't even
really own the account that got banned
in the first place none of that really
mattered to valve though the account had
yampi's
name on it which was all they needed to
lock him out of majors forever
for most people it didn't even matter if
yampy was the one who cheated on the
account that got back banned
after all he was 14 at the time a
literal child
even if the crime happened does the
punishment fit we live in a world i live
in a country in denmark for example that
if you kill or murder someone you may
get away with
five six seven eight if it's really
extreme 10 11 years
of punishment that's from murdering
another human being that's from taking
away
a life from earth now put that into the
context of jampi maybe being 13 years
old and cheating in a management game
and he's getting ponies for life
absolutely ridiculous absolutely absurd
the only silver lining here was that
covert 19 had shut
down majors for the foreseeable future
meaning that yampi's vac man was
relatively unimportant until they came
back but yampi was still teamless
still backmanned and now embroiled in a
lawsuit
even though his talent was undeniable
things didn't look great
and then when all hope seemed lost ends
shocked
everyone by signing gambi
organization
at a time where they were struggling the
thing that makes it even worse
is that they know you're here they've
heard you and you know they've heard you
as well you
you're just walking into all these
crosshairs and you can't do
anything about it you have to hit your
shots there and it just doesn't happen
vitality with so many players
on the angle unsurprisingly are able to
pick up the victory here on morocco
they get adventurous inside of lobby and
be massive he's just been tasked to hold
back he sees the leg of yampi
and well he's looking for one other
sonny
one and done that's going to call sergey
back into action on the a
site reign and olu exchanging kills here
so it is the two versus two
and a little bit of damage off of the
deagle but it's not quite enough
olu oh he's got a chance but it's
stripped away
and faze in absolute stunning fashion
they string 15 rounds together
in a row although they were a top finish
team
they were hardly an international
contender but
that hardly mattered to gambi
was on a team that supported him and
allowed him to play against the best
players in the world
things were looking up it's not going to
be too much of a difference in terms of
the score line
as they would have six match points
anyway
to go against oh this is just two easy
fans
yeah mate they're just taking the fight
straight to them and it's working out so
well
alu and yampa the two orbits closed down
the game with annihilation
anyone they saw they picked off sunny oh
they're gonna get all the information
they may not want it
but they're certainly gonna get it one
to the right great shot great double and
yumpy's having two stellar ct pistol
rounds
oh it's stolen away that is so cool
yampi taking down a coal the smokes are
down today but it doesn't even matter
what a great way to take all the
initiative away gambie with a quad kill
he's running for it he wants that ace
he's looking for it there it is
what a monster unfortunately the
honeymoon didn't last long
within three months ends fell apart and
yampi got benched
yampi's bad luck seemed almost cosmic at
this point
but it was about to get worse because
the finnish courts
had sided in favor of valve as it turns
out yampy and his legal team
sued the wrong valve they went after
valve gmbh
a european subsidiary that was created
in 2016
a year after yampi got back banned
yampi's future as a cs gopro
was in shambles his team didn't want him
no one else was willing to sign him
and it seemed like his vacman would
never go away
and that's when he made the decision to
break up with csgo
and as for the future i don't think this
is a surprise to anyone and tell her
there has already been some rumors about
it but
i will be switching the walrus valerant
was a clean slate a chance for yampi to
finally compete at the highest level
without being
held back by his band yeah just kind of
mixed feelings for even for me you know
i created cs for so long so it's just
it was not just easy to make it like the
decisions just to go
go to another game it may have been a
new game but with an op in his hand
it was the same old yeah
[Music]
oh my god
two no scopes go fast go fast by stream
team liquid quickly picked him up and
gave him a simple goal
qualify for valerian's first ever
international land in iceland
it seemed like ampy had finally found
his true home
but with his luck things could never
be that simple we are gathered here
today because
last thursday valve published a stunning
unexpected and altogether
earth-shattering blog post
in which they decreed that certain vac
bans
would no longer be permanent the update
to the long untouched vacman rules meant
that yankee could suddenly compete in cs
go majors again
four months after he already quit the
game what it was like four months after
i switched so
it was kinda i would not say unlucky
because i'm super happy where i am but
if i knew in january
i'm gonna get on bad in four months i
would probably not have switched but the
question of whether or not yampi would
return to cs go would have to wait
first he had to qualify for iceland
oh my god is this just good sewer look
at this they're all funny hopping up
the massacre is so yummy it's a reload
and still finds
okukos b is definitely not the place you
want to be
when it comes to these after plant
scenarios it can be topped off
from yummy the fin is just going flashy
at this stage and
what is that a ridiculous retake he
didn't even need his teammate in the end
he didn't even need a scope tom this is
what it comes down to one round between
the winning
and losing of this one yampi gonna
deliver the bullets and the knives yampi
up on top that's two that's everything
they need liquid
walk away being the emea challenger
playoff champions
the amount of doubters this team had the
roster changes that they made
the hard choices they've constantly come
through with
and they walk away in the first place
spot iceland awaits with his first bit
of time off since the vac ban was lifted
the mp finally addressed a question that
was on everybody's mind
i'm gonna stick to wallarant this is the
game i wanna win right now
and i think it's better for me i wanna
win everything involunt
after everything he'd been through the
mp wasn't going to crawl back to cs go
he finally found a game that could
appreciate him that wouldn't leave him
in the lurch for
years even now when i got unbanned i got
some like
interesting offers from cs but i didn't
didn't accept them i'm really happy
where i am right now so
and iceland was where he proved that he
was truly committed to valorent
that tp that's available still for gtm
he could make a very quick rotation back
into middlebury
okay that's nine kills in two rounds
he's just aced it
they won't take down yappy but with that
detain they have the psych
under control b and j in a critically
important position
leaps through with the blades and there
it is
straight in the face tells it goes down
yappy with the defuse
those guided lights coming out for the
mini map to get info
well there it is the judge comes to play
and that's the
prime gaming flawless his teammates are
falling like flies
yampi still with the dash online free
for a kill dash still
up which gives him the confidence to go
out for more
yampi helped liquid take fourth place at
the first ever international valorum
tournament and
given he only picked up the game a few
months ago it's fair to say he's doing a
pretty good job
i think right now it's just qualifying
for the champions
and that's like uh at the end of the
year that's like the short term goal
and i think in the future i just want to
be the best team
and best player in the world but more
importantly yampi is finally the master
of his own destiny
his toxic relationship with cs go is
over for now
he dumped the game that never gave him a
chance and he is thriving and valorent
he finally found a game that can
appreciate him now all he has to do
is dominate it
oh why did you steal my ass
i can't i sound like shrek
paul yeah my my sincerest apologies to
to mr
um i don't remember his name oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm i apologize to you mr yumpy i can't
pronounce your name i'm bad at it
who needs two p's you know